what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i have a special guest
um she is known as canada's dating coach
and she has helped
me personally i've definitely done
one-on-one sessions with her would you
like to introduce yourself to the
channel
listen i remember before i branded my
business
i was talking to a friend of mine who uh
um you know sort of like was a sounding
board for me and i was talking about how
matthew hussey came to canada and went
on the maryland dennis show and i said
i said why is he he's from the uk why is
he here i'm canada's dating coach
and this is how my name came about
because it was just so
yes like because this is my thing i'm
not here to change
a person i'm not here to change some
people i'm here to change everybody
and i will i will start country by
country before i can do the world
and were you inspired by matthew hussey
was he one of the reasons you started
um because i i know i've heard you say
on your channel that you feel like he's
not completely honest to woman would you
say that's true or false
oh i i absolutely call him up for being
dishonest i
believe if you're going to coach people
and how to be successful at something
you should be leading not being a
textbook teacher
and so what matthew hussey is not in a
stable
long-term relationship and he's never
had a stable long-term relationship
and i teach women to avoid
guys selfish short-term thinkers so guys
who play them guys who take advantage of
them
guys who keep them as side pieces and
matthew hussey dated camila cabello for
a full
year everybody knew except his
followers so there's the media following
them around
talking about them radio interviewers
are saying howard camilla
right so everybody knew everybody knew
but if you look at matthew has his
social media platforms doesn't talk
about it on his youtube channel
like like never says i'm in a
relationship
on twitter on youtube on instagram never
once said
i'm in a relationship so
why because the women who follow him
are the money and some women follow him
because there's this sense of connection
this is like my wannabe boyfriend
and he doesn't want to take that away he
doesn't want to lose followers because
now he has a girlfriend
which is a selfish short-term thinking
thing to do because
he could he could disclose his
relationship that everybody else knew
about it was no secret
but he could disclose it to his
followers and take them on the journey
of how to have a successful relationship
but he didn't and do you know why
because he doesn't know how to
because he's a player he's a guy he's a
pickup artist
and incidentally she's 10 years younger
than him well it's interesting because i
had a similar
thought um i remember when he was
talking about cheating in an interview
and he was saying well sometimes girls
accuse guys of cheating
so much that they do it and i'm i'm
thinking i don't
i don't i mean i don't think it's okay
for a girl to keep a choose accusing a
guy of cheating but that's not an okay
thing to do just because she accuses you
of it
and that was like the first like red
flag where i was like he might be kind
of a player you know
he has he absolutely is um so
what i actually wanted to start with was
you have a
rule that shook the dating
like the dating advice community by
force everyone was talking about it the
no kissing for three months dating role
could you tell me how you came up with
that
so i read a book um by steve harvey act
like the lady think like a man
and he talks about no sex for three
months and he says look if your
fence is low anybody can step over it
if you have a higher fence the strong
ones are the ones who are going to be
able to climb over to get to you
so having a no sex for three months
means guys who are just around for sex
are going to move
on guys who are more serious about a
relationship are going to stay
but i took this further because i did
more
studying um sociologically
psychology within the psychology of it
and within the biology the question that
i said to myself
is listen i might not be having sex but
if i'm kissing that person i'm not
kissing anybody else
so what's the difference why am i taking
myself
off the market for somebody that i
kissed
why are we kissing on the first second
or third day why is it that after we
kiss on the first second or third date
if somebody else is can i take you out i
say no i'm seeing someone
why is this happening i'm very big about
the whys i need to understand
so then i thought well there must be
something about the kiss there must be
some chemical we are chemical beings
every emotion we have every impulse we
have is a chemical reaction
so then i googled his chemical and i
started going through the
peer-reviewed journals of what the
chemicals are in a kiss
and the physical responses your body has
to those particular chemicals
and i learned about phenylethylamine
which i mispronounced and i know it but
i like the way i say it because it
sounds better to me
um right so phenothalamin or p-e-a
and and the research that that i i did
in this
it really opened my mind up to how
we are getting messed up when it comes
to dating because we're doing a kiss to
see where it goes
but the kiss makes us exclusive right
saying no to somebody um after that
first case it makes us
exclusive which means it made us stupid
we kissed somebody we don't know and
became exclusive and now we're on this
journey we're we're hooked we're in
until until we break up right until it
gets so distressing to be in this
relationship with this person
we need to dump them or they dump us and
then we have to grieve and then we start
all over again
so it started with my own dating journey
my husband and i
you know we've been together for 15
years we fought for 10 years
we broke up a few times during some of
those breakups i dated other people and
that's like the first one where i was
like out to date other people
was when i got that book act like a lady
thing like a man and then
you know didn't know sex worth three
months rule and i was like let me do
some more research on this
no kissing makes a whole lot more sense
so then i started using a no kissing for
three months dating role
so we my husband and i had a few
breakups i use the no kissing rule i
dated two incredible people that i would
have kissed had i not used this rule
but because i wasn't kissing them my
husband won me back
had i kissed those people and he tried
to win me back i would have said no i'm
seeing someone well and it's funny
because people hear this
um no kissing for three months dating
rule and they think you're a prude
like they think that they think that
you're um promoting
chastity or something like that and
that's the furthest thing from true the
more i watch your content
so what have you learned about my
sexuality
and my openness to sexuality
oh well you used to be a stripper right
yes
and you you went to swingers clubs
and you've brought home like girls for
your husband and stuff
right well for for us yeah yeah yeah
sorry
it wasn't so and and so here's the thing
i have nothing against playtime i have
nothing against exploring your sexuality
i have nothing against you having fun
for the sake of having fun but there's
two different mindsets there's play time
and there's
long-term relationship and you shouldn't
be using like when it comes to play time
it's
am i attracted to you and do i trust you
that's how you find your playtime
partner
you shouldn't be taking that same method
and using it to find your committed
long-term relationship
because the list here should be am i
attracted to you
do i trust you are you trustworthy are
you honest do you have integrity
um are you responsible do you have work
ethic do you make me laugh more than
anybody else
do we have do we share the same goals
and timelines right like
there's so much more and so you should
be waiting to find
out who they are and if they satisfy
this
list before you guess and get into
relationship if you want a
long-term relationship if you just want
to play go for it
but and by the way just just about the
the thing about me bringing girls home
for my husband
he wasn't allowed to kiss or to touch
them but
did he go to town on me when i was
having
um so this is
are you familiar with the manosphere at
all
maybe not okay so the nanosphere is
basically like
men's dating content um so i've learned
like basically in the last three months
i've learned a lot about dating like
from the men's point of view so like for
example one struggle i've never
really thought about is that a lot of
guys feel like used for their money and
their resources like
because girls will go out with them and
then just
never talk to them again and just try to
get you know the date or whatever out of
them
does that make sense something never
thought about yes i see that yeah and
it's honestly like i have seen girls do
that i've seen girls like that and it
makes me mad
because men are
they're generous right and they want to
show you
who they are they want to show you that
they will be a good man
for you so they'll take you out to
dinner they'll mow your lawn
they'll shuffle your driveway because
they want you to feel like you can count
on them
and there are girls right so i i
definitely said to
to my frames generous long-term thinking
selfish short-term thinking
guys and girls or men and women and
girls will take advantage of men take
advantage of that generosity
and so i stand with men and i don't want
them to be taken advantage of
and this is why i say the first couple
of dates
need to be nothing more than a beverage
and a walk
because i don't want men to get taken i
encourage
even if a man says let me take out to
dinner i encourage my women to say
how about we take a walk instead so that
you know men stop getting used
yeah and um i think the manosphere is
just a lot of
very frustrated men with um with like
they've dealt with a lot of girls
um like for example a stat that i never
heard of um is that
80 of divorces are initiated by women
and if you go to college educated women
um
90 of them are initiated by women which
is kind of nuts to me have you heard
that before
i have and and i understand
men have a put the head down and get it
done
mentality and my my husband went through
the same thing
so with his ex-wife they were fighting
all the time nothing he ever did made
her happy
um you know he he worked very hard to
support
the household and she said
i want a trailer by the river for some
place to go
in the summer and he said well i will
have to work more
to make that money and she said that's
okay
go do it and so he did work more to
be able to get that trailer and then she
said you work too much
you work too much and so he said to
himself you know what i'm just gonna put
my head down
and and be a father um despite all this
fighting
and she was the one who came to him and
said
i want to get a divorce because nothing
he did was ever good enough
everything he tried to do to make her
happy never made her
happy yeah and that's the story i
keep hearing um from the man's
perspective is i did this for her i did
this for her
i did this for her and she still
divorced me
anyway and it's um it's given me a level
of empathy for men that i never really
i guess thought about before because you
don't hear a lot about men's struggles
um so that leads me into you're really
you talk a lot about being in control of
your emotions
yes um could you tell me a little more
about that
so i mean you know if if we take a look
at you know what my husband went through
when you're always looking for someone
else to make you happy and you're not
working on creating your own happiness
through meditation through releasing old
emotions
through being conscious of your thought
patterns and redirecting them through
being
aware of what it is that you have and
generating gratitude for it um if you're
not doing that if you're always looking
for exterior sources to make you happy
if you're always creating lightning rods
for your over
abundance of stress fear and anxiety
because your amygdala which is your
fight or flight
which is the party brain that produces
stressor and anxiety if you don't shrink
that part of your brain
you're always looking for a story to
assign for the reason why you feel that
way and we look to the person who's
closest to us and we go
it must be you it must be because you
work too much it must be because
we don't have enough right so she wasn't
happy because
she didn't have a trailer by the river
she was unhappy because she did have it
but he worked too much to pay for that
and so there's always this story to a
sign for the overabundance of stress
fear anxiety whatever the emotion is and
so you make your partner the lightning
rod
and so when you take responsibility for
your own emotions
and you learn how to make yourself happy
then your relationship becomes much more
stable
um could i have an example of
something i can't really relate to the
trailer by the river so like if i was
feeling unhappy about
um say the way i look would that be
something that possibly could be taken
out on my partner
uh you don't say i'm pretty enough oh
so then you you project it onto them but
it's really an emotion of your own yes
oh that's really interesting and so you
teach women and men but i would imagine
most of your clients are women
eighty percent of my clients are women
okay yeah that's what i imagined um
you so you teach women and and men too
to control their emotions
and you talk about meditation a lot yes
could you tell me more about that and
what the benefits are
absolutely so like all of my self-help
books are
seven steps uh grounding which is
meditation
clarity overcoming fear connecting
discovery intimacy love this is your
ascension to be successful even when it
comes to business
and so meditation basically alters your
brain structure
so harvard did a study they had people
come in and do an mri scan go home
meditate for eight weeks come back do
another
mri scan when harvard looked at the two
scans side by side they saw the brain
change shape
in two places the amygdala shrank and
the hippocampus
increased in gray matter so amygdala is
stressed fear and anxiety
the campus is introspection and
compassion
meditation creates the perfect brain to
have a healthy relationship by reducing
your capacity to feel stressed fear and
anxiety
and increases how you look and think
about yourself
in other words you become the best
version of yourself so that helps you
become the best partner to someone else
100 okay so how often do you recommend
people meditate a day or a week
so weekly it should be 140 minutes a
week
minimum okay especially when you're
starting out when you're starting out
you need to get that shrinkage
happening once you get your amygdala
shrunk and you are
less emotional in a negative sense
you are less reactive um you're less
vomity right you're less short you're
less impatient
um once you get that once you achieve
that maintenance can be
like about 10 minutes a day but when you
want to achieve that shrinkage you need
to get more shrinkage
than stressors and it has to be enough
minutes a week
so 140 minutes a week would be on
average 20 minutes a day sometimes you
might
skip a day so you make up the time
yeah and it's crazy i've been doing that
the last couple of months
and it's so weird being on the outside
looking in when you're just so much
calmer than everyone around you it's
like nothing
can nothing even bothers you anymore the
way it used to
thank you for saying that i love hearing
people
tell me the effects they get from
meditation is so rewarding
i already know how the manosphere is
gonna take the no kissing for three
months dating rule
um and the way that like the manosphere
i would say and i don't necessarily
agree with this but they would see
the no kissing for three months dating
rule as selling
a used car for new prices does that mean
oh man oh she gave it away so quick
before why is she suddenly waiting yeah
it kiss with me by the way that's not
the magno sphere that's the guy
owes fear yeah so the selfish short-term
thinkers
like listen every every male
will protest the no kissing for three
months dating role it is
normal they have a 24 7 fertility cycle
mother nature didn't design them with
that desire
to hold back sexually
24 7 means i'm ready to
go and so what they've done is they've
infiltrated
that into the dating sphere
let's go and and we as women went oh
[ __ ] all right if you say so instead of
saying wait a second
let me think about how i want to
approach this um
and so the the gyosphere is very
um tight into that methodology they like
it it
serves them the magnosphere is gonna go
oh oh oh that sucks
but it makes sense so you get a very
different response and that's
that's why introducing this just the
fact that you
introduce it is going to reveal a lot
about the person sitting across from you
yeah and that's the
biggest i would say disagreement that i
have with the man of sphere is i always
say like i think there's some value in
getting
to know someone before you sleep with
them before you kiss them
um but they really teach guys to sleep
with girls as soon as possible
so they can have the leverage but i'm
thinking what kind of healthy long-term
relationship is that
yeah and it's not the value of getting
to know somebody before it's the logic
of getting to know somebody before and
the people who are teaching
are guys so it's guys teaching
males how to be guys get that kiss right
away
be courageous move in for it that's what
guys do that's what
men do that's what high value men do
high value men don't ask permission they
move
forward and it's just it's such a
[ __ ] rhetoric
but the reason why it's there is because
on a subconscious
level listen we are born of fundamental
knowledge we are born with the
understanding of what
laughter is and how to laugh and a baby
will laugh without ever being shown how
to laugh
we we understand things we understand
that people who made us are the people
who should protect us and when they
don't it
messes us up big time and so you know
this is where anger issues come from
when our parents are abusive
our little child brain says that's not
fair because it understands
what should be and that's that's not
fair that hurt that's not fair turns
into anger as we get older that's not
fair
and so you know we we understand things
on a fundamental nature including
how we function together and one thing
that
males fundamentally understand without
ever being taught is getting a kiss
creates exclusivity
because that's what happens when we are
in relationship seeking mode not
a play mode because listen i think
little bark has five guys at night
and i probably have done that but you
know like like
and and not get attached because there's
no part of my brain
that says i'm looking for a partner i
want a partner i'm seeking a partner
and we kiss somebody our brain says mate
selected
and shuts down the red flag alert and
the males
know that and that's why they move in
for a kiss because they know a kiss will
make the vagina
exclusive and they want exclusivity on
the vagina
they don't care about the girl they
don't care about the person they want
exclusivity of the vagina
and i always say on the channel you know
if you're going
you know for casual stuff then sure go
for it but if you're looking for a
long-term partner i don't think that
stuff is gonna work
right you can have luck or good
intuition
but people who lack either right the
ones who keep picking the wrong partner
and getting
hurt over and over and over again luck
or
intuition are not working in their favor
and that's where you need a plan
have you heard about hypergamy and do
you have an opinion on it
yes so i you know obviously as a dating
coach i get
i get a lot of guys who come to my page
and
and um and they're bringing this this
this toxic
male mindset and so that word is
associated
uh to women suck because they level up
women suck because there's something
better than
okay and and use that word and they say
what is wrong if if if she
finds somebody more responsible more
committed
more hard working uh you know more
devoted
more conscientious more thoughtful what
is
wrong with her leveling up if a man
finds a woman who's more
grateful more appreciative more of
service to him
what is wrong with him leveling up
there's nothing wrong with
leveling up um so i actually have a
different
interpretation of hypergamy and i'm
curious to see what you would say to it
so
when i my understanding of hypergamy is
that
a woman will hook up with a guy on like
a certain level
but he like wouldn't date her does that
make sense
oh i've never heard that so so what
they're saying is that
like let's say a girl um in terms of
being a compatible partner a
good partner she's a six right she hooks
up with a guy that's a nine
right the nine would never date her he's
just hooking up with her but then the
girl that's a six
won't date anyone that's like unless
he's
a nine okay
yeah i mean i i've never heard that
version
um i just heard it associated to
she's she's always looking for something
better she'll leave behind
you know the one who who um
you know doesn't measure up to the next
thing she's looking for
and so their fear with what they're
saying is why should i get into a
relationship
because she's just gonna leave me when
she meets somebody better
yeah no i've definitely heard that too
um
but what i think of is guys that are
frustrated
because they'll have like a wife and
she'll leave them for someone better
that didn't want her for anything other
than sex
right um
so as that didn't want her for anything
about sex
i there there's there really has to be
more to it than that
there yeah there's i mean the way that i
understand
how men and women interact men
are looking you know it's
guys are looking for science men are
looking yeah
men want to have that family unit men
want to
look after their family and and be
successful as a husband and as a father
that's a man
um guys it's all about the sex mainly
about the sex that's why they don't like
the no kissing for the most dating role
because like look this isn't about you
or us
it's about the sex so that's
i i've never heard it in that way
because that's making a a female more
like a male
right leveling up four sex when it comes
to
how we mate select and there there is
like a seven year itch
right because we are designed by mother
nature to not be monogamous for life we
that that's not our design i i have a
crush on robert downey jr
obviously i'm not monogamous by nature
even though i love my husband incredibly
but you know so that seven year itch
is okay i i selected a mate repair
bonded we made that baby
now that baby is five six years old
which means it can now
forage for food and run away from
predators on its own and now my dna says
okay
for the next baby in other words the
next bundle of dna
make sure you find the best dna code
because mother nature has designed is to
always want to make the strongest baby
possible and so men will choose a more
fertile female
what's the more fertile female well the
younger ones and
women will choose a good provider what's
a good provider well usually that's
somebody who's making more money than
the one i left behind
so that's the dna drive
our bodies are being driven around like
a little like
from dna like a little alien and in
black
no that's actually so interesting
because you always hear in the
mannosphere that men aren't monogamous
by nature men aren't monogamous by
nature but it turns out women aren't
either
we cheat just as much as they do but we
don't get caught as much as they do
really how do they know that
well like um so basically doing
uh what's it called like when you reach
out to people and and you just you get
their answers like studies polls
that kind of thing um so there's there's
been multiple
uh studies that are done and and
basically
the percentage of women who cheat versus
the percentage of men
cheat are just about equal there's like
there's a small small number of
difference
but men tend to be more um
bragging about their conquests and
so it gets out there a little bit more
they're not as uh
good as we are at hiding the steps that
they took
they get caught more yeah i i don't
think men are um
overly careful like and then women are
so good at finding things
too oh yeah
well we have the multitasking brain um
we're also very good at fine details
like honestly like like i
noticed if i feed my husband uh
you know meat that was factory raised
versus meat that was
grass raised i see his physiological
body
change so i notice fine detail women
notice fine details so i think that's
why we're a little bit better at
catching
if our partner is cheating can you talk
more
about the common differences between men
and women
and what fights you see in relationships
that that leads to right
so communication is a huge one i get a
lot of women who say
my guy doesn't express his emotions i'm
like baby girl he
is but he's doing it through his actions
he's not using words like you do
and you think he's not expressing
himself because he's not using words
but you're not looking at what he does
and what would you say for women
or like men to women what is the biggest
complaint men have about women
uh not being appreciative not being
grateful for what they do
and that's why you teach in meditation
to say to
list the things you're grateful for in
that day correct
yes yeah okay what are the most
common dating mistakes you see men and
women make
honestly using that no not you not using
the no kissing for three months dating
role
kissing a stranger and hoping for the
best is the biggest mistake you can make
the absolute biggest mistake you can
make this is how we get into
relationships with guys who are cheaters
guys who are seeking the attention of
other girls um guys who don't have a
work ethic
guys who spend all day on video games
um guys who just don't care to put the
work in to be
a partner and be present so
we play the holding game as i get so
many messages from women who are like
you know i did tick tock today seven
months in usually it's eight months
this one seven months in and every time
i bring up where are we
he says oh i want to take it slow i'm
not ready i got hurt in my last
relationship
so the biggest mistake is
kissing somebody having sex giving them
all those benefits
hoping it will turn into a relationship
and really not even
paying attention to who they are um
there's 12 character traits that are
going to help you define if he's a
selfish short-term thinker or a generous
long-term thinker
but we fill in blanks he's cute
i find him attractive he's not working
really hard right now
but i'm sure he will one day right and
so we create stories inside her head of
who this person is going to turn into
well and people don't men don't
understand that it benefits them
too i've seen so many guys that are
blinded by a pretty girl
yes that you know she could be an
absolute wench
but she's very pretty you know so they
don't see any of the red flags
yeah everyone can benefit
from using this role whether you are gay
or hetero male or female
it you know like i just finished writing
the perfect play for men
right and i i teach them why you want to
use that no kissing for three months
dating role
and you want to use it because the woman
who says i can't with your mom's her
first kiss
is hinting her self-esteem and whether
or not you want to have sex with her
well if if she's hinging her self-esteem
on that
you know the days that you say i'm too
tired
i'm too stressed i don't have it in me
this is going to turn into how you know
you are such a problem for her because
you're not giving her that self-esteem
boost by playing the numbers game when
it comes to sexuality
so her insecurity will be insurmountable
um there's you know some other examples
that i use in there i can't think of
them right now
but there's so many reasons why a man
would want to do that so that he can
really step back
and observe her and see how she operates
how she is
there's so many things you're gonna find
out about somebody when you give them
time and space to reveal themselves and
i i teach them one of the things to look
for like
if the only topic of conversation she
ever
has is how other people are
you know this and that so all she talks
about is is other people
then this is somebody who's never going
to
have an interesting conversation with
you because all she focuses on
is is diminishing other people so she
can elevate yourself
herself no that's absolutely true um the
next question i have is what do you
think of the phrase men are trash
oh i don't like that i i really don't
because
men are amazing
men are amazing generous long-term
thinkers are amazing they're worth their
weight in gold they deserve to be
cherished and loved and appreciated and
love is a verb it is a verb love is what
you
do and men are so willing to do
and they deserve our attention back they
deserve
us to be in service to them as much as
they're in surprise to us
yeah that's um i totally agree with you
there was a point in my life where i
definitely
felt like that on some level and then
there was a point where i had to think
who's choosing these men you know
like who i can't blame everyone else
because i have brothers that i love and
my dad is great so i can't i can't blame
an entire gender for my decisions
so when we say when we say men are trash
that's kind of the equivalent of saying
i'm so tired of
[ __ ] and my book for women on dating
is
no more [ __ ] and i want people to
understand i'm not calling people
[ __ ] people who are selfish
short-term thinkers
are not [ __ ] the reason why we call
them [ __ ] we as
women is we are in relationship mode
we fall for somebody who's a selfish
short-term thinker we try to get them
over here hey i keep trying to have the
water we talk and he keeps brushing it
off and telling me he's not ready
so we try to bring them over here
they're not coming over here because
this is where they're happy staying and
then we say
he's such an [ __ ] he's not giving me
what i need
when i say no more [ __ ] i mean
let's stop pissing ourselves off by
choosing somebody over here wanting them
to be this
let's isolate these ones and choose the
best one
here and we're all going to stop saying
men are trash when we do that
yeah and that's what i really love about
your books
especially the no more [ __ ] i've
read that one and you really take
accountability for the way you feel
about men
and the way that you feel just in
general day-to-day
so that's what i love like the most
about your books is it's really
holding yourself accountable for your
emotion and empowering you
yes when your mental well-being when
your mental and emotional well-being
is in someone else's hands when it's
dependent on someone else's behavior
you are disempowered
go through if they don't come through
for you
you are unhappy you are unstable
when you say i have control of myself
i'm controlling my destiny i'm using a
no kissing for three months dating role
i'm meditating i'm going to choose the
right person and be the right person and
i'm going to detach my emotional
rollercoaster from other people's
behaviors
when you do that when you have control
of yourself you are empowered and so
i want you to control your emotions i
want you to be in charge of your
environment
i want you to select the person not wait
for somebody to choose you
and then get pissed off because they
don't want to give you a relationship
they just wanted you for sex
so empowerment is what i am teaching
who's happy the partner you choose is
happy
and the children you make are happy can
you
talk more about the character traits to
look for in a partner
so there are 12 and and i i don't give
them all away because i want people to
get no more [ __ ] i dangle that
carrot
but i'm gonna give you some of them so
control
if somebody gets upset because they
don't get first access to your time and
money
they are a controlling partner if
they're telling you what to do where to
go who to see
what to wear they are controlling a man
is not controlling
a healthy relationship has freedom
if he doesn't give you freedom to be
yourself
he has to go you gotta dump the
[ __ ] another one
is financial responsibility you cannot
build a life with somebody who's not
financially responsible
so if you're looking for the person that
you're going to buy a house with and
travel the world with
he needs to be financially responsible
if he's lacking that
say no um do you is it the same
for women to men
uh so women should in order for a woman
to be a generous long-term thinker
she does need to be the 12 character
traits
in addition to that there are some seven
qualities that a man looks for in a
woman
um being a dependent having her own life
her own friends her own interests her
own ambitions
is one of those a a generous long-term
thinker is a
confident man who has ambition and so
like attracts likes so they're looking
for a woman who is
confident and ambitious but another one
that's really important
is not not needing him if
we say like listen we've been taught to
be strong and strike and not need a man
for anything and that's fine
that's fine absolutely but if there's
nothing he can do for you that you don't
let anybody else do for you like for
example
my husband is my spider killer my
husband is the one
i go to and i say baby i've had a hard
day can you put your arms around me and
tell me everything is going to be okay
right giving him certain roles that
he has that no one else does for you
gives him a sense
of place and importance and he says i
belong here because there's a reason for
me to be here
if there's nothing he can do for you and
you communicate that
over and over i don't need you i don't
need you i don't need you he goes then
why am i even here yeah that's something
that um
i think a lot of women get wrong and
they say i don't need a man i don't need
a man because
a lot of guys will just say okay and i i
don't need a man
but i give my man a sense of purpose in
this relationship
a ra have you heard of basically that
like rich man are allowed to cheat have
you heard that narrative at all
so it's i i've i haven't but i can
certainly pick up on that
um so it's
i actually i have a i have a client who
is
like her her boyfriend is successful and
um you know the way that she got in a
relationship with him is he
cheated on his his previous girlfriend
and that's that's how he went from
relationship to relationship was like
before leaving one he would just start
the next one and then leave leave the
one
and listen
people who have a lot of means tend to
have a lot of opportunity
and so that's kind of where that tends
to come in
if you don't want a partner who cheats
don't get with somebody who cheated on
somebody
to be with you if this is something you
know about them already
then don't start a relationship thinking
it's going to be different
what about um people that have
arrangements do you think that's okay
like bill gates and melinda gates had
for you know 20 years 20 plus years
so anything that consenting adults
choose to do that make them happy i have
nothing against
okay cool um do you want to talk about
your books
yes yes yes so i wrote
nine books i'm writing book number 10
right now um
because i'm crazy apparently i have a
lot to say
so no more [ __ ] is what this can
help you make sure you choose the right
partner
but usually i start this with come back
queen i don't even know why i jumped
into normal [ __ ] right away so so
the progression and that's why i have so
many bugs because there is a progression
to having
a healthy sane relationship so comeback
queen is a way that helps you get over
your last relationship let's let's wipe
the slate clean
let's heal your heart let's get you
started to get into what you need to be
getting into
um so come back queen helps you heal
your heart no more [ __ ] helps you
choose the right partner
after the first kiss helps you solidify
that relationship by not turning little
things in a big
fix that [ __ ] is going to help you have
a zero conflict relationship
and that is not suppression that is
resolution so managing your emotions
managing your behavior so you don't have
unnecessary fights understanding your
partner's differences
and being able to bring up the things
you need to talk about without there
being defensiveness in other words no
fighting uh custom made is a book that
helps you if you're co-dependent it
answers two questions
what is my purpose and how can i
monetize it if you are codependent if
you're sending your partner a text
message
and getting upset if it takes them an
hour to reply you're watching your phone
instead of living your life
so that means you're making your partner
your purpose and so you need to make
your purpose your purpose and
custom-made will help you do that it is
a workbook
uh dating 101 is a textbook for
teenagers
and my nerds this is the one that helps
you understand the driest behaviors and
emotions behind love
fake love need not apply how to um how
to get rid of posers
losers scammers and predators say yes to
goodness is what that teaches you how to
be happy not only in your relationship
but outside of your relationship
and the perfect play is the book that i
wrote for men
that teaches them how to get into
relationship with their generous
long-term thinker
could you talk about how you
went from fighting all the time with
your husband
to a fight-free relationship
yes and my god you guys if you want that
do get fixed that [ __ ] by the way this
book works if you're with a generous
long-term thinker who loves you
does not work if you're with a self-a
short-term thinker
so what i started to do is i got into
meditation
i started to reduce my anxiety i stopped
vomiting on my partner i became
calm and unreactive to him which means
i started leading the way to more
emotional stability and
functional behavior in the relationship
a great thing about meditation
it really opens your mind that
are precise in terms of dealing with
your own issues
so i remember thinking uh you know i got
to talk to my husband about this when he
gets home
and then the voice in my head which
really started getting super
clear with meditation said what are you
not asking forgiveness for and i went oh
[ __ ] that's a good question
and so you know what had happened is is
you know with the scales
i did my husband has a piece of poo on
his side i gotta talk to him about that
piece of poo
and then the voice said what are you not
asking for guinness for and i
immediately thought about three things
and i went oh [ __ ] i think the scale's
just evened out here
i don't need to talk to him about
because there's some [ __ ] he's not
talking to me about
so i'm not going to start a conversation
because there's things
i need to be taking a look at myself and
so he came home that night and it gave a
smile on the kiss and i said hey baby
and that was it
right so i really started being more
aware
of fairness right it's not fair to ask
for anything you're not willing to do
first
um i started being more aware of
fairness being aware of my own emotions
being aware of my own behaviors
i said to myself i don't want us to
fight anymore and so then i said well
that i need to make my behavior as much
my intent
and so i became very intentional with my
behaviors towards this goal and not
fighting anymore
and when my partner with his over sized
amygdala came home and said
you do this i said baby when's the last
time you remember me doing that
very nice and sweet and calm because i
didn't react to his anger
and he went um well it's been about
three months and i was able to say
the best predictor of future behavior is
past behavior if i haven't been this way
in three months you can anticipate
another three months of me not being
that way
and do you think maybe you think i'm
still doing this is because your
amygdala is oversized and you were
assigning a story to this
stress fear or anxiety reaction that you
had because your amygdala went let's let
me give you an emotion
what did he say to that
didn't have anything to say that
because and and so what started
happening is
you know you know the term i couldn't
see the forest for the trees
he couldn't see his own issues because
we kept
fighting and he kept saying himself we
are fighting because of her
when i took myself out of the fight a
fight is fire meeting fire
when i stopped reacting with fire and he
would come at me with fire and it wasn't
turning into a fight
he started to have to understand that
the reason why he felt that way had
nothing to do with me right when he
comes home and he says you do this
and it's been three months since i did
that he has to acknowledge that the
reason why he feels that way
doesn't have to do with what i'm doing
it has to do with what he's
thinking wow
wow that's powerful it is powerful the
one part of your book that i really
liked was
when you said you can't ask anything
you're not
for anything that you're not willing to
do yeah
because i realized um i wanted to be
taken on these nice
dates uh which is nothing wrong with
wanting that but when was the last time
i took him on a date
right and i i realized i was like wow i
can't ask for this if i've never done it
myself
yeah so was it after that was it smooth
sailing did he all of a sudden
did you just stop fighting like that no
it was
so no it really it took years
for his brain to adjust to the notion
that this is how we are
now and for him to fully relax
into this new environment that i had
created
because it was 10 years of fighting and
the best predictor future behavior is
past behavior
and so it did take some time for him to
fully
understand that the
time and space to catch up
um and so how long would you say that
took
five years uh it took a good
three years three years and then you
were fight free after the three year
period well we have stopped fighting
we'd stop fighting for three years so a
fight is fire meeting fire i took away
my fire
and we haven't fought in five years
because a fight takes two people and i
took myself out of the equation when it
came to fights
but he took three years
to 100 percent release the fight mode
and no more fire on his side
and what's it like being in a fight-free
relationship oh
boy it's so magical it's so magical
people say it's normal to fight it's
abnormal to not
fight it's healthy to fight have no
idea zero idea it
so when you have a fight you retract
your good feelings because you get
defensive you pull in your good feelings
and then your good feelings come back
out after you make up and then the next
fight happens and you pull your feelings
in
that's retraction and your good feelings
only grow so much because there's
this constant retraction going on and
then they come out and then they retract
when you stop fighting there's no more
retraction
the opposite of retraction is growth so
what happens is your good feelings for
each other
simply continue to grow because there's
no longer any retraction
so you said you went to therapy before
too with him
right and that wasn't overly effective
we did couples therapy
and then we also did like a group
therapy weekend and
we gained like like i you know the one
thing that i got for my couples therapy
was um i learned the term cognitive
dissonance that's like the one thing i
got from that
um when it came to the the group therapy
thing
um we did some exercises and so
you know those ultimately did help us
create some healing but it didn't help
us stop fighting and we were still on
the brink of divorce and it wasn't until
i started meditating
that things really started turning
around so
neither of those two things that we went
to taught us to meditate
had that taken place maybe we would have
gotten better
a lot earlier so if you guys want to
find me uh
tik tok is a great place i i'm active on
there every single day
i'm releasing tic tocs i'm doing lives
all the time uh i
also have a youtube channel tons of
videos on there i have a podcast
guys go to my tech talk go to my
instagram like just go to tick tock or
instagram type in canada's dating coach
go to youtube type in kant and stairs in
google type canada's dating coach
you will find me absolutely everywhere
you're going to see my books are
available on amazon
if you want an audio book though you
have to come get it through my website
or through the link tree in my instagram
or on tiktok but i've got a ton of free
stuff for you like i've got
a free book a free meditation guide if
you hit that meditation starter page
um you can also get a free long distance
guide if you want
i love to give you so much because
i want everybody to change and to have
the goodness that i found
well thank you so much for coming on and
taking the time to do this i truly
appreciate it i'm also gonna
um guys if you want to find her um all
the links that she's talking about are
going to be in the description
do not forget to subscribe to the
channel and bring that notification bell
i will talk to you guys
next time